[Musique]
il se passe un truc bizarre quand on
quitte cette ville plus on s'éloigne
plus les souvenirs deviennent floues
mais moi je suis jamais parti je me
souviens de tout
[Musique]
à la santé des ratés on a fait un
serment on lui jure tous
si ça est pas mort
[Musique]
si ça revient de choses on reviendra
aussi on n'a pas réussi à le battre
culte leurs cornes on peut pas laisser
recommencer
y'a quelqu'un bonjour
[Musique]
pendant 27 ans
j'ai rêvé de vous afin de vous
ma future maman
il faut vaincre ça
pour tout je ne faisais que ces faits
pourraient saluer l'effort de
l'intérieur et bientôt ou pour appuyer
chappuis
tu as menti
et je suis mort
auj